all right let's hear from a few more folks via
the david pakman show discord server which you
can find at davidpakman.com discord let's go
to trudy from glasgow trudy you're on the air
hi david how are you i'm very good thanks
how are you i'm doing well i just wanted
to phone up and uh thank you very much for
the common sense that you bring to things
my pleasure um it's just very nice to hear your
point of view obviously living in scotland we're
back in a full lockdown at the moment so um we're
all staying at home i work at a primary school
for five to twelve year olds so i'm still at work
um but everyone else is at home so how are things
looking from the standpoint of vaccination
um at the moment i think in scotland we're
just sending out letters for the over 60s to get
an appointment for vaccination that's interesting
it's being done by uh paper letters are being
sent out that's i've not heard of that before
yes yeah you get uh you get an appointment
um to go to your local vaccination center
interesting and is that is it going more slowly
than people would like i mean i guess no matter
what it's going more slowly than people would
like but yeah i mean it's certainly going
more slowly i think than i would like um but
obviously they're they're doing all they can
or you hope or you presume that they're doing
all they can to get as many people vaccinated
as possible of course yeah and is there uh how
how strong is the anti-vaxx movement in scotland
it's not very strong it's not strong enough that
i'm aware of it oh that's good that's good if
you're not aware of it that's a great start like
i'm very aware of it in the united states right
i mean i know of a few people who have said oh
i'm i'm not sure if i'm going to get it or not or
um but that really that's just a personal point of
view it's right it's not really a whole movement
have you um do you know people who have been
vaccinated and my mom just had her first dose
last week so oh okay and side effects how were
they nothing really she felt a little unwell
you know a bit of a headache for a couple of days
but that was all wow yeah yeah i was down with a
fever 36 hours i was shocked truly wow right okay
yeah no she had the the oxford asked us anyone so
ah okay okay yeah that one is not
currently available in the us but
um very it's great that that there are so many
vaccines now on the precipice of approval well
good trudy i i appreciate your comments and hope
uh hope people get vaccinated soon thank you for
your time my pleasure all right trudy from glasgow
what a polite perfect phone call unbelievable